john you're up next
uh you've been married you're divorced
wrong john
[Laughter]
look at you in a bit uh
so what is your blanket policy right now
like actually
talk about how you handled money in your
marriage and talk about what your policy
is today
yeah so i was i was yeah blue pill alpha
very idealistic and i i gave up
uh control of the finances early on
in the relationship and a major mistake
i think
uh some of the best advice i ever got
was something josh koscheck said to me
before i got married and he said never
uh never let him see your bank account
never let him see
uh how much money you have i just kind
of laughed it off because you know i'm
idealistic and oh it's true love and
whatever
we're a team we're partners
right and it got to a point where uh you
know i was doing everything myself
having no problems running running the
show doing the investments paying the
taxes i had it all handled
um because i did things my way she
didn't like the way i did i did a little
bit older i'm uh
i like i like getting the i like getting
the bills i like i like
writing the checks out you know
old-fashioned
and uh she didn't like the way i did
things so she kept just bothering me and
harassing me and bullying me to like
let her do it just let me do it let me
let me uh take over so we
you know because if i if i was late on
something and we got a little bit of a
late payment
you know it was my fault because i was
still using mail to pay my pay my bills
and eventually she you know she takes
over the finances and
she's running everything and i after a
while i don't even know what's in my
bank account because
she's a bank account nazi
if uh if i had to do it over again
there'd be
no way that you'd ever know what i'm
making at all
you um shared a story when i was talking
on my channel
on the plane to win about how you came
home from work one day and
and she was all like hair makeup and
nails were all done she just blew i
don't know a few hundred dollars on that
and you're in a position where you had
to sell your truck i was looking at
selling my truck because we were i just
got cut from the ufc
uh well no i was uh i just
had a draw with bj penn i bought a
second home
um you know i was injured so i was out
for like nine months
like was was was struggling money-wise
for a little while
and i was like remodeling this house so
uh
while i'm going through all this stuff
i'm like damn we need we need some cash
so
in order to kind of fund my training and
my house and and everything i was like
gonna sell my truck i love my truck
it's like my phone it's my favorite one
of my favorite things
and um i like just had it lifted and
everything you know
like painted so uh
not looking forward to getting rid of it
but like what what i was hoping to get
for it was like 10 grand under what it
was
i was going to get for it no and
it kind of hurt a little bit and then i
came home one day and like i was about
ready to sell it that day and when i
came through the door
you know hair's blown out nails makeup
everything's
you know to boots she probably dropped
like 500 bucks that day
just just doing her doing her up
and and based on what you learned from
that um
and where you are today like how would
you manage money in an ltr on a
go-forward basis
yeah i'm never going to i'm not going to
mix that ever again like my
accounts are going to be my accounts um
you know
if i ever enter into some kind of
significant
ltr you know uh like aaron said man
like everybody's gotta work nowadays
just about you gotta have some kind of
revenue stream coming in um
so yeah i would i would have to have
maybe a joint account
if we were gonna do long term but that
that'd be if you know if we're having
kids i don't i wouldn't see me doing
anything
long term or supporting anybody unless
i'm putting babies at them
yeah it makes sense
you